hey everybody it's Mike from order flows
and welcome to today's uh video it's
it's uh Friday night it's September uh
23rd anyhow markets closed we did have
that nice uh late rally we you know we
ended up the day down about one just
over one and a half percent I think
we're down about 1.6 percent
um we had that nice late rally which I
think uh helped some Traders out you
know from the low of around 36.60 all
the way up to 37 11. but you know that
is just uh it's just a small rally in
the overall uh action of today you know
we sold off from you know the 37.80 down
to 36.60 so over uh it was about 120
points moved down and we regained some
of it late
um I'm going to talk about something
interesting in the order flow after the
close
um that can be sort of a precursor to
what to expect we may see on
the weekend or when we were open on
Sunday night now the market that I will
be watching see what happens you know if
there's any gonna be anything
interesting is uh you know I'll be
watching the crypto Market over the
weekend we'll see if we get uh
get a push lower down uh below you know
into the 18 thousands over the weekend
if that's going to weigh on the market
you know the people don't like to admit
it but crypto is kind of closely tied to
the equity markets now so it's not uh so
much for decentralization you know it
pretty much moves in tandem with the
equity markets but uh today in the order
flow some interesting things let's take
a look at it and you know really what I
was talking about today is volume where
it appears in a bar and you know what it
means right because you know
if you watch the order flow if you look
at a footprint chart this is my order
flows Trader footprint chart that I use
and
you know every bar has decent volume I'm
talking about the e-minis here but
there's certain times where you sort of
have heavier volume being clustered in
certain areas Okay so
most common areas for heavier volume as
opposed to sort of your normal uh
transactions going through are going to
be the highs and the lows of the day
right at highs and lows you know reason
it's a high or it's a low if it's a low
because it's support it's a high because
it's resistant so you know trading 101
you sell resistance you buy support so
there's always going to be a bit heavier
volume you know at lows of the day
transacting or at the highs of the day
that's why when you see like for example
here this Market coming off right
uh you know Cash open we're going down
lower you're seeing these volumes down
in here you know 1100
um you know 700 you know a thousand
people oh you know you got heavy volume
down here well yeah I mean that that's
where you expect the volume to be right
people
are buying you know that was a support
level that that's why it was
you know just below the low of the day
you know people viewed it as a support
level for whatever reason so I'm
expecting to see volume it's really what
you want to be focused on
is where there's heavy volume
that's not an area that you'd be
expecting support or resistance because
when that appears then there's probably
something else behind it right as
opposed to trying to buy support or sell
resistance and today there was some
um good examples you know around this
3712 area here okay let's just sort of
find it okay so you know nine o'clock
you know 9 9 30 you know we were trading
rotating around you know 3712 it had
been an area that we're trading around
right you can see it in here right got
all the way up to you know 37 16 and
three quarters 37-12 areas just right
around here I'll just draw that line so
you can see how the market is just sort
of rotating right around that area a few
times
um but then we start coming up here okay
we come up into it we get this uh
you know what is that like kind of it's
kind of like a star candle pattern you
know we probe up then we come off okay
if you look at these volumes that's
going through here
okay what do we got we got 276
561.
hmm okay so the volume volume on this
bar is four thousand three hundred ten
percent of the volume happened at this
37 11 and three quarters area 561 right
that's like 11 of the volume of this bar
at this trading on the offer at 11 and
three quarters okay and again you know
remember this is an area we had just
been trading at earlier right right in
here okay so it's not like you're not
gonna say well that that's your
resistance area because no that's an
area we had traded around started coming
off now we're rallying back up there but
this time we have some Supply coming
into the market the 276 the 561 the 248
just this volume on the offer here you
add this together you know you got over
a thousand contracts right that's over
25 of the volume in the bar at these
three price levels on the offer
okay we know the offer is passive
sellers
what does that mean it means those
people
defending that price there they're happy
to throw in their offers let the market
come up to them
fill them
and get into their trade
Market hit that area so it came off
right you see even though it's a green
candle and normally you know I'd prefer
this to be a red candle but you can only
trade what the market is giving you so
it's giving me this green candle but I
know we're well offered highs okay our
high is 12 and a quarter we're closing
at nine and three quarters okay then we
trade down then we come right back up we
start coming back up towards that level
at 12 again 11 and three quarters we
trade 108 11 and a half we trade 338 at
11 and a quarter we trade 775 at 11. we
trade
509 even the one tick below here
at 10 and a half we trade you know 322.
if you were to add that up you know it's
a 322 to 509 775-338
you know the 108 that's 2 000 just over
2 000 contracts that's almost over half
the volume not over at the bar Trade
four thousand contracts but
this is up just under half it's 2 000
and change 2052 contracts just trading
in this little area here in this bar
okay so I know again it's coming in
right around this area that we had just
been trading right around here so I mean
if you were to take this volume from
here up to here
draw some lines okay I I know already
this is sort of forming a resistance
area based on the volume that's going
through right we're coming back up again
we're trading into it but we're seeing
you know just Delta at Price here you're
seeing you know on the offer on the
offer on the offer so we know that as
we're coming back up in there we still
have those passive sellers there
and you can see the market just sort of
came down a little bit again started
trying to test it within the tick of the
sort of that area but we did trade up to
11 you know where it's a little volume
before so now this is my area right this
is my resistance or you can see how it's
working looking at where the heavy
volume is concentrated here which
relates to the heavy volume being
concentrated here it's not surprising to
see that if we're going to come back up
in there you still probably have those
passive sellers there to absorb whatever
buying is taking place and it it works
right those sellers are there
and the market came off okay again we
sort of came back up there finally sort
of got through it trading some heavier
volume
um you know to sort of get through that
area and it's over but this is your clue
here you know with the order flow it's
not like okay I read this volume here
that's my level in the sand market can't
go past it you know Dynamics change in
the market
you know and especially on a day like
today where we got 120 point range
everything's you know people's
perceptions of the market is changing
literally by the minute so it's it's not
uncommon to see the market come back up
and take a level but this was assigned
for you you know to take this trade at
least in here right yeah you got one two
third time a charm right again remember
if this is your resistance area it's not
like it's going to be resistance forever
it's going to keep bumping into that and
you can see it came in here came off a
little bit finally got through it up in
here this is one of the problems I see
with guys that use just regular
technical analysis they draw a line I
think that's it that's the line Market
can't get past this then the market
tests it Market test it and it just
blows right through it so when you're
trading these areas
in order flow right you got to realize
things have changed
right what was bearish now is starting
to turn bullish for whatever reason but
the trade to have is you know getting
short somewhere in here ideally around
you know 10 11
covering it down here at five five
points and you know just a few minutes
this is a 30 second chart so it's moving
a little bit faster but you know whether
you're looking at a one minute chart you
sort of see the same things
okay so you know just look for where the
heavy volume is transacting
okay then uh you know a bit later right
you'd come back up here right
um you know we trade all the way up to
16 before we started selling off again
but there's some other uh interesting
things in the order flow here so we're
making these lows oh I forgot what time
it was I think it was around 11. okay
don't don't hold me to that time let me
see here let me just scroll through it
do do
here right so this Market came you know
we came down right we made those new
lows started rallying back up a nice
move you know getting through 80s from
36 80 straight up you see all these
points controls mostly all higher see
nice buying Deltas positive Deltas you
see nice buying imbalances
and then finally we work all the way up
here just under 3 700 obviously the
figure 37 Double O
it's a nice psychological level and you
can see the heavy volume coming in here
right the 587 this is what stopping
volume looks like right the 587 on top
287 beneath it you know 220.
again this bar is trading just under 4
000 contracts 39.23 and literally a
quarter of your volume is just happening
in these three price levels right in
here at the high just at the High second
level third level so you you know that
that's what price defense really looks
like okay it's that heavy offers
even though it trades right because
what's happening is absorbing the buying
that's going on and you see the market
immediately had a nice sell-off this is
one you can just go with as soon as the
bar closes and starts trading down in
the next bar you just go with it you
know right away there at 97.
um you know and then it just sort of
immediately pulls down to
um you know the 93 92 area
and it just sort of goes sideways but
look at that level okay this is the
level here
sort of draw it in
you see sort of came right back up to
that level where you had that volume
before right you had this is stopping
volume that's what these ratios tell me
people ask what are these blue numbers
or the black numbers above or below my
bars these are order flow what I call
order flow ratios it it's the ratio of
the volume inside the bar at certain
areas so I know if it's a excuse me if
it's a small number
um between
one and zero so 0.48 is between one and
zeros telling me the stopping volume if
it was the opposite if it was a very
high number like 58 then tell me it's
price exhaustion but I know I got
stopping volume just by looking at the
volumes here very simple okay 587.
that's a lot of volume at a price
in one in a bar
on the e-minis
okay and it's again 587 into you know
total volume is 3 900.
so what does that work out to it's it's
you know I can't think right now
10 not 10 it's like
six or seven percent of the volume of
this bar right at that at the high so I
know that's what's called stopping
volumes volume to stop a move back up
right all you got to do is you simply
make a note F6 on ninjatrader draws the
you know you know F6 you just click it
you see the pencil is enabled you just
draw your line right here that's your
Line in the Sand watch for the market to
come back up there what's it going to do
came back up here came off came back up
here again we're putting in some volume
that's two what is that 235
you know it's the opportunity to get
short somewhere around 99 with the stop
just above 3 700 because I know there's
this price this level is being defended
and it sold off
quite nicely I'd been happy to just get
five points out of this move but again
it seals off it keeps selling off you
know down to
um 90 down to you know did get down to
85.
I wanna even though this is a bullish
ratio in terms of price defense the
volumes aren't that strong honestly it's
just 137 it's 160. but you know that was
a nice move
now late in the day after right after
cash closed right we had that big rally
going into the cash close
what was that about 50 points it's 60
3660 all the way up to 37 just under 37
uh I'll get 37 10. but cash close where
what time was it right in here this
volume is heavy volume right obviously
cash closes the heaviest volume what I
thought was interesting was this this
1541 coming in here this came in
three minutes after the cash close
on a Friday
so
to me I read that as you know okay there
was probably a lot of orders going into
the cash because you see those volume 60
000 and here's eighteen thousand is
eleven thousand sixteen thousand you
know one minute afterwards is still at
eighteen thousand so it's it's a lot of
contracts going through well over
you know it's 125 000 contracts in this
five minute period actually these this
is two and a half minute period because
this is a 30 second chart so from
um 58 30 seconds to
you know 30 seconds after the cash close
it's trading 120 000 contracts which is
big but then a few minutes later like
two and a half minutes later that big
volume we don't usually see big volume
coming through in the market afterwards
now it could be someone says you
know I supposed to sell some stuff on
the clothes I forgot and come in and
work it out but when I see a size like
that coming in after the close it sort
of portends what's going to happen what
I think might happen over the weekend
and I mean the market did sell off
immediately right after that but then it
sort of rotated back up again going into
the Futures closed just sort of trading
right around that level so you know
I I just found it interesting to see
that big volume come in sort of post
cash close which is something you don't
normally see
so just uh you know it's one of those
things where someone put a gun to my
head you know would you take a position
on Sunday on the open yeah I'd probably
be looking to trade it short but again
you know you could watch you know for
your junkies out there keep an eye on on
the crypto Market see which way they're
going to go this weekend if we're going
to get a dump or not
crypto holds steady then we'll probably
open up steady
on equities so anyway guys have a great
weekend I got some things coming out for
you guys over the weekend so uh be sure
to like And subscribe the channel
um so you get the notifications when I
put post new videos so again thanks
everyone bye-bye